there's an idea called the red sneaker
effects by Francesca Gino that suggests
that people who break social norms are
seen as higher status so her original
experiment was run academic conferences
I think this is early 2000 when there
was a very strong norm what people are
expected to do was turn up in business
attire so what she does is as people
attend these conferences she's noting
down how well dress they're often very
scruffy - very smart once she's got this
data she then goes and finds two people
whose dress code she's allocated on her
little job Nast and how many citations
they've got how many times has their
work being quoted by other people and
what she finds is that there is a
inverse correlation between smartness
address and number of citations so it is
the very successful academics who are
breaking all the norms of that dress and
once you start thinking about it it
becomes very believable that you know if
you're the intern and you turn up to
work your dress prayerfully you get sent
home if you're the CEO when you turn up
looking like a mess Rory Sutherland
my mum still does my washing I pay her
every week to do my washing yeah but the
problem is obviously with the new
essential travel only lockdown I can't
see her so the first thing that she said
after Boris's announcement wasn't are
you okay what's business gonna be like
it's do you know how to work the washing
machine so look ladies and gentlemen
welcome back the crowd goes crazy for
Richard shut-ins return to modern wisdom
how are you mate very good thanks very
good pleasure to have you on I cannot
wait for today first things first
Richard did you know that sex toy sales
have increased by 71% in Italy for every
crisis someone someone's winning that's
it everyone's talking about what's gonna
happen to the price of oil what's gonna
happen to the price of gold no one's
talking about what's happening to the
price of silicon are they so tradable
commodity and I said I was going to tell
you as well about gangs in Rio de
Janeiro yes
yes so to the listeners this is not
going to be covered 19 focused I promise
you we're gonna give you some awesome
insights into advertising and marketing
but it's too topical not to drop this so
gangs in the favelas in Rio in a forced
to lock down from 8 p.m. every night and
they put statements out on a website
don't know if it's their website
and the statement reads if the
government won't do the right thing
organized crime will how amazing that
you've got a place where typically the
gangs are the people that have more
control than the police on the negative
side and now they're just stepping in to
enforce a lockdown
yes I mean I mention this yes some stuff
interest thereof if something spreads in
a favela presumably it goes like
wildfire and so close together but
that's sir
yeah I hadn't seen that or miss that
completely yeah no it's a look what
we're talking today we talk advertising
I talk a lot of other stuff my first
question I've got for you is how do you
create the perfect advert no small
questions no small question well on one
hand you could say that it's something
that's impossible to create a formula
for now that's not just a complete of
Asia the question it's the idea that
probably the biggest task an advert has
is to be noticed and because if you
haven't noticed everything else is is it
relevant and one of the things we know
from psychology is the what is
distinctive is far more likely to be
noticed we're hardwired to notice what
is what is distinctive now with all of
psychology that's not just speculation
on my part there is a lovely set of
experiments as a lovely set of
experiments under the name of are the
isolation effects or the von restorff
effect so it's called the von restorff
effect because there was a pediatrician
psychologist in the 1930s called Hedvig
von restorff in 1933 as a classic
experiment
she gives people long lists of
information sometimes there might be
it's on every line there's three digits
sometimes that might be letters a B Y
next line sjq third line CB Y and then
every so often if she throws in three
numbers one six four and then she goes
back into her letters again she gives
people five minutes look at this long
list of information trust getting to
remember as much as possible takes that
list away and then sees what people can
recall and her key finding is that if
you give people long lists of letters
that most likely to remember the rare
numbers if you give your long list of
numbers then most like to remember the
rare letters so why I say you can't
really have a formula is if you have a
formula and everyone adopts it that
formula becomes
defunct what you actually need to do is
find out what is the formula wrong
alright everyone in your categories
using what the category norms and
virtual kaskus will have some some quite
specific norms of behavior find out what
those norms are and then or you probably
want to list out all those norms which
ones do you have to adhere to because
there's a very good reason which ones
are there for traditions sake alone and
those the ones that you want to break I
love it yeah and if you look through a
lot of categories you see these very
specific ways of behavior so there's a
wonderful Twitter add a Twitter handle
called I think say my perfume ads for
sale and it's just these increasingly
surreal scripts you know about David
Beckham being in a court and leg of ham
falling through the sky and shouts out
guilty and they only work because
everyone knows that's the kind of
ridiculous overblown motifs that
happened in perfume ads or you've got
the car ads with a beautiful car going
around the corner lots and lots of
categories have very fixed ways of
paying the best thing to do is probably
understand what those norms are and then
and then break them yeah I remember
seeing you tweet an article that you did
for marketing week nine percent of
digital ads I looked at for more than a
second
so 91 percent of digital ads are looked
up for less than a second yes I think
that data remember that was a wonderful
eye tracking company that Mike Follette
runs called lumen so it's a lovely data
in the they've create this great
technology that gets embedded in
people's computers and it essentially
tracks where their eyes look so it's
quite a robust finding the the average
time people are look at ads is that is
is a fraction so I think from that
you've got a couple of points you've got
well distinctiveness is a tactic to be
noticed
secondly placement is hugely important
and it's a metric that a lot of
programmatic trade doesn't take into
account what's that mean oh so
programmatic is just automated trading
so you go and look at a website and this
is an my IRA speciality but if you're
looking at a website the site has
certain data on you you might know that
you're a bloke it might know you're in
your 20s or 30s and then it will auction
the ads that you see to various parties
and programmatics essentially people
just bidding for how much they think
you're worth but that takes into account
a lot of data about you what that study
by lumen shows is that actually where
the ad appears very important the longer
someone spends reading an article the
longer they end up looking at the ads
for not factor the ad itself but in fact
so if you're on the site is a greater
probability the ad will catch your
attention so actually there's quite a
powerful argument so things like news
websites where people will spend you
know a minute on an article a much more
valuable than eBay where they might just
be a speculator how come if it was even
was good or bad actually but he might
sites where people would we'll just on
for a second or two so yes I'm lovely
lovely research about that yeah but
important just much more transient isn't
it some websites you know you flicking
through stuff I imagine I always think
how terrible the conversions must be on
tinder adverts you know everyone's just
swiping as fast as they can in any case
that don't give me an advert that's
gonna be up there like that's not gonna
be on the screen that's a better this
that's verb for tinder ads are pretty
pretty brutal so it depends what the
kind of experience is like as well
there's a lovely body of work all around
mood and I guess it depends how
successful you are in tinder but if
people are unsuccessful and they're a
bad mood there's an awful lot of
evidence showing that again going back
to noticeability
people are much less likely to notice
ads so there was a study done by Fred
Brunner at the University of Amsterdam
and he got more than a foul
and people gets them to flick through a
newspaper and after they've done so he
asked them but they're in a good mood or
they're in bad mood they were relaxed or
stressed and then he gets into try and
recall as many ads as they can and what
he found was that people were much more
likely to notice the ads when they were
in a good mood rather than the bad mood
now what I love about behavioral science
is that you don't have to you know you
don't have to take his work on faith
alone you know you don't just have to
believe it and you know you either
believe it or you don't
the great thing about all these studies
is all the researchers in the public
domain so you can take his ID here with
a few tweaks rerun it for yourself to
see if it works for your brand or your
particular problem so I call Egan I
reran he's study but not interested in
no disability we were interested in
likability so he did exactly same thing
we show people loads of car and taxi ads
got them to rate how much they liked
their creative and then we cut the data
by people's mood and we saw huge swings
you know people were rating the ads is
more likeable so I think was that a 50%
swing no racing is more likeable when
they're good mood run bad and it sounds
a bit bizarre at first but I think
there's a couple of explanations there's
a and there's an argument from Daniel
Kahneman
Nobel Prize winner back in 2002 he says
that for most of there's an evolutionary
point he says that for most of our
evolutionary history if we were in a
good mood its signaled an absence of
danger and therefore it mitigated the
need to think critically so if you're an
advertiser having an uncritical
accepting ordiance is probably a pretty
important thing and I think there's a
there's a second part of if you're in a
bad mood and you see an ad with the
price and the benefits well you probably
put a bit more weight on the downside
and the price and the opportunity cost
whereas if you're a good
you're optimistic you very focus on the
more positive parts and it's again it's
something that just never really gets
discussed amongst brands and media
agencies but there's a whole body of
work that's jests this targeting by mood
or at least waiting at mood should
should be far more important yeah we've
all been there right you've all been in
a car where you've had a crap morning
you spilled your coffee down yourself
you rushed you late for work someone
cuts you off and that person on a Sunday
afternoon is you were just chilling out
coming back from a stroll kids you know
you wouldn't you wouldn't have thought
twice about it but they are your worst
enemy on the planet on that Tuesday
great shoes their morning with coffee
down your shirt
so what's the implication then for
brands and advertising campaigns is it
that they need to be hyper conscious of
the medium of delivery the timing of
delivery stuff like that because you can
write the best vibe by your argument
there you can write the best copy
beautiful adver wonderful idea and if
you get it wrong timing wise people's
yeah mood you've 50% of the time maybe
so well I think that's put two
implications you could the great thing
with behavioral science and this is an
analogy that really sufferings made is
is it's not like physics he says it's
not that you know in physics the
opposite of a good idea is a bad idea
what Rory Sullivan says is it in
behavioral science in psychology people
are so complex and nuanced that the
opposite of a good idea it could be
another good idea so what's interesting
about that mood point I think you could
take down two very different ways one
implication and this is where I default
takes my background is in this areas is
as you say well you put more emphasis on
reaching people in a positive mood now
with existing technology you can do that
to degree it's a bit crude but you can
do it there are lot studies like the IPA
touch points diaries and time diaries
which show that people are much more
like it's been a good mood in the
evenings and in the mornings on Fridays
and Saturdays than they are on Mondays
and Tuesdays so you've got some crude
ways of reaching people by time of day
you probably got some slightly more
accurate
you could reach people during comedy
shows or in the cinema rather than on
the tube there are potential much more
accurate ways of targeting mood coming
down the line there was a study done by
his name escapes me at Brigham Young
University I think of it but halfway
through the show they did this study
looks at people's mouse movement on the
computer and what he showed was that you
can tell someone's mood by the
smoothness of their mouth so it well if
the cursor is moving very smoothly and
evenly
people tend yeah it's a signifier people
have probably a good mood if it's moving
in a more jagged horrid way signify that
they're in a in a bad mood so if he's
correct I think might have been Geoff
Jenkins but double check that one if
he's correct well it's not too hard
therefore technologically to start
serving ads depending on on how the
mouse is moving across across across the
page so rather than reaching people the
propensity be in a good mood I think
that might be a much more accurate way
at all but then the other angle could be
koteki you could forget about the medium
and prioritize the creative you could
say well we have the ability you know to
put people in a good mood through
likable characters like the MiG humorous
jokes like the economist arts you know
that there are ways for the creative to
put people in that that positive mood
and then we can harness the benefit you
unless it create your own environment
you become the precursor to your own
message yes and you've probably got
that's probably got greater potential
than the medium argument because the
problem with a lot of these media
arguments is you might squeeze out an
extra five or ten percent efficiency
from new targeting but most sites
well you'll either have to pay a
technology provider to get that data to
do the targeting or you're asking for
a specific subset of a media owners
audience and they'll probably charge you
for that so you've got to make sure they
uplifting your performance from the
cycle to incite outweighs the increase
in cost the great thing about that green
a crave argument is this far easier way
to make it work financially mm-hmm so to
make a good advert we need to get
noticed first and foremost that was that
yes not if we're not noticed
everything's yet 'less and you you had a
great point about this way you said a
lot of advertisers and marketers focused
on the second step optimization of
perfecting the ad rather than just
getting noticed yes
there's a lovely quote from Dave drops a
wonderful blogger an advertising amazing
creative and he says something like the
most important line that should appear
on every brief never does and that is
this advert must be no ystem remembered
and he says the fact he's never seen
that on a brief in his life suggests
that marketers take notice ability for
granted I think he's right I mean I've
never known ever fixates on that problem
it's always about the conveyance of the
attributes of a brand there should be
more focused on on noticeability
mm okay I mean the other we've we've got
ourselves noticed we've got we've yes
we've we bypassed that first what we
doing next
yep well well this is a kind of a hybrid
because the great thing about this about
the solutions being noticed also has
implications for what people think about
your brand so there's a so we've said
one of the ways to get noticed and there
are others you know personalization
links but distinctiveness is it's a
really powerful one the brilliant thing
with that is there's an idea called the
red sneaker effect by Francesca Gino and
some other colleagues that suggest that
and it begins with per word I think was
readings with people it suggests that
people who break social norms I've seen
as higher status so her original
experiment
was runner academic conferences I think
this is early 2000 when there was a very
strong norm what people are expected to
do was turn up in kind of business
attire shirt and jacket for blokes so
what she does is as people attend these
conferences she's sitting there and
she's noting down how well-dressed there
are from very scruffy to very smart
once she's got all this all this data
she then goes and finds the people whose
dress code she's allocated on her little
chart she then goes and ask them how
many citations they've got a citation
isn't academics kind of quantification
it's a bit of crude run but
qualification for how successful they're
how many times are their work being
quoted by other people and what she
finds is that there is a inverse
correlation between smartness of dress
and number of citations so it is the
very successful academics who are
turning up very scruffa lee who are
breaking all the norms of that dress and
once you start thinking about it it
becomes you know I think very believable
that you know if you're the end earn and
you turn up to work your dress very
scruffy late you get told to sent home
if you're the CEO or if you're the rock
star academic and you turn up looking
like a mess well everyone will just
laugh at it out of where what mr. Esav
cravats and in an ad agency absolutely
was it even twenty Roedean that might be
what might just think you know it's a
lunatic yeah that a wonderful example
and what she argues is firstly that it's
only people with high status that can do
this and then she shows in other
experiments the people were remarkably
attuned to it so if they see you
breaking a norm they then take out
higher status from it so and this is
then a bit of a leap that's her stuff is
about people so I made a bit of a leap
to brands
and I'm doing some research at the
moment to try and see if this works
but arguably if consumers are aware of
the category norms and you radically
deviate from them perhaps in the same
way as people will get perceived higher
status so will so will the brands so I
feel of distinctiveness one because it
gets around the note stability problem
but it's also conveying some of the the
positive attribute of a brand signalling
yes yeah yeah so that that was a little
bit of a fudge a little bit of a hybrid
I don't want to miss that down but that
sing about tea you've got attention the
next thing you want to be achieving is
memorability
and there are some lovely studies from
academics around this as well and one of
my favorites is this mighty called the
generation effect so do you remember the
Cancer Research ad either the end of
2018 maybe mid 2019 so it was talking
about the second biggest cause of cancer
is OB Blanc s Blanc T why yes yes I do
yes a bee sting yeah there was a big
hoo-ha R about that and there was debate
about whether it's fat Shamer or not I'm
unfortunately because of that
significant debate what got lost was
they were using a really clever tactic
to get people to remember their core
point and that taxi is the generation
effect so the agency and I think it
might be know normally I'm not huntin
sure they used an experiment from 1978
boy graph and Schley Mecca called the
generation effect and what they
essentially did is not quite this but
very similar they would give people
lists of words so let's say you get a
list of one group gets a list of animals
fish dog weasel cat elephant they try
and remember as they're given this list
with von restorff people have to
remember as much as they can
next group get the same list of animals
but rather than being written out in
four just like that Cancer Research ad
you don't see fish FIA Shu CF blank Sh
people are given the same map time with
that list of words they get the list of
words taken away from them and then they
have to recall as much as they can and
people were 14 they remembered 14% more
words in that second condition when they
had to generate the answers themselves
and what graph and Sulekha argued was
that
if you just give people a list of
information they process it too quickly
too easily but it just kind of washes
over them if you put in a tiny little
bit of friction if you make them
generate the answer the brain has to
process some of that information it
becomes more memorable I think maybe
teachers push this more than advertised
you know don't just read your textbooks
write stuff down quiz yourself all that
sorts of stuff so you've got this
interesting technique for generating
better recall generation effect you
there are some examples like cancer
research like J and B whiskey of very
literal interpretations that add
now having blanks in the copy to make
you'll remember it all well and good but
you can probably only do it once twice
without it looking a bit weird it
becomes the new norm as well and right
yeah well potentially there is that as
well but what I think with all these
biases that we discuss is that where
they are most powerful isn't when people
don't think of behavioral science as the
end in itself where you get there you
get the best strength is applying the
creativity of marketers mind and the
insights on behavioral science and if
people interpret these findings much
more laterally I think that's when you
get the bigger impact
so bilaterally I would argue some of the
best bits of copy apply the generation
effect not by removing letters but by
giving people small puzzles so the
famous economist ad by David Abbott amv
i don't read The Economist Management
Trainee age 42 I think that's a lateral
interpretation of the generation effects
he didn't go out and say people who read
people who don't read the economists are
unsuccessful they gave they gave you a
little bit of a puzzle you had to work
that out for yourself
therefore it becomes a bit more
memorable so that would be one tactic
for a living I love that I heard a Robin
Greek
a negotiator for the FBI I had him on
the podcast a little while back and what
he said was the one tool which is used
by FBI agents who were trying to recruit
assets if they want to try and get
information out of them is rather than
so let's say I want to get your date of
birth I might say to you I bet I can
tell what horoscope you're your new Pitt
Pisces right and you go no I'm not I'm
Aries yeah okay yes about 1985 no 1984
and you're like you have this desire to
fill in the gap right so there's part of
that which it's playing on also Philip C
Brown the guy who wrote I'm gonna get
this wrong I think it's make it stick
add him on the podcast about two years
ago now and his synopsis of an entire
lifetime learning how people learn is it
doesn't matter about repeated exposure
it matters about repeated recall so the
Fineman technique uses this right it's
learn your thing then teach it to a four
year old it doesn't matter how many
times you get exposed to something it's
how many times you're forced to recall
that from memory and if you think about
the obesity advert you've got yet kind
of the edges of both of those things
those mechanisms going on there
that someone thinks I want to I want to
complete that because the Zeigarnik
effect says we want to close the loop I
don't like yes yes it is uncompleted up
there and then there's also this side of
it that is you touched on having to
force people to pull some cognitive
power out they've had to deploy it you
know that's more work than some people
would have done speaking at their spouse
in the morning
hi darling how are you yes good bye
Thanks like that you know that's just
the the classic morning orange juice
chat and yeah by doing that I think
you'll have the repeated recall I think
you'll have got that as well
put video of two examples were teaching
and negotiation and I wonder if
sometimes advertising is in danger of
looking to inspiration always from other
advertisers no flicking through awards
journals and actually maybe people like
teachers who are all about the past
information
people to remember things you could
probably get a very different set of
inspiration again you know going back to
the point of distinctiveness you you
don't want to be learning the same
things as your competitors yeah okay so
we've got we've got distinctiveness
we've talked about some different ideas
for that how can I work on my creativity
and not just rehash new versions of my
old ideas what are some ways for me to
kind of bolster my creativity when I'm
looking for new things in my adverts and
new ways to to come up with ideas well
this is move away from my especially
because I don't write ad so move away
from our speciality but I would argue
there's one sense of having a different
set of set of inspiration from other
people one area that I have done
research on is maybe the danger of who
we're trying to appeal to when we're
creating advert so we've had we've
thought we've talked about generation
effects as being a way to create
memories improve the probability of
recall another tactic that does that is
something called the the key turistic so
it's an idea from Matthew McGlone and
Jessica Raab that's right that don't
have to pronounce a certain topic - I
think and what they did so that it's
called the key turistic because it's and
it's the idea there we find phrases that
rhyme more believable than non-rhyming
phrasing what yeah I wasn't particularly
a strong believer this one at first
ready but they have a lovely experiment
so what they do is they get two groups
of people first group are given a list
of kind of fake proverbs and it was
something like you know what the first
word might be you know the first prophet
might be rose unite foes and there'd be
a another proverb the other group see
the same proverb but R in an unripe way
so woes unite enemies
so they'll they'll have this you know
list of 10 proverbs say some rhymes some
don't rhyme and then the other group
have the the mirror image they then say
to people how true do you think this
this lead be these proverbs arm they
rate them on her on a sail and what they
find is that when people have seen the
rhyming version if they get in compared
at the results the group with the
non-rhyming version the rhyming proverbs
are seen as significantly more
believable now interesting pressingly at
the end they asked people directly why
did you believe this proverb or not does
it have anything to do with the rhyme
everyone swears block and it's the
content that they think it's nothing to
do with everyone says there's nothing to
do with the rhyme so if you ask people
directly they send you off completely
the wrong direction but if you do this
wonderful test and control approach you
start to see the power of rhymes and
they argue I think that we offer we
often confuse mental fluency with with
truthfulness now I then took that again
this lovely wave with behavioral science
you can take these experiments and rerun
them for your own ends we did exactly
the same study but this time we gave
people the lists of Proverbs in the
morning and then rather than ask them
where they believed them or what not
we've gotten to try and remember them in
the afternoon and this was amongst
colleagues so you know dubious
robustness but I think up memories
probably saying that is true for an HD
staff as much as anyone else and what we
found is that people were thinking that
two times more likely to remember the
rhyming phrase than the NAM rhyming
version now what's interesting with a
C's that does believability and notice
ability to massively important things
for adverts having a rhyming strapline
but if you go to look at historic
collections of adverts and I did this I
went to they news international archives
so with a colleague we went all the way
back to 70 years looked at hundreds and
hundreds of newspapers
nads and what we saw was a really clear
Pam whereas in the 1970s loads of ads
had a rhyming strapline by the naughties
in the 2010s
it was down to a handful it was 5 or 10%
you know all those great things like
once you pop you can't stop
Pringles don't be vague I adore Acura
now these are all 20 30 40 70 years old
they're completely fallen out of fashion
now we've got that's fascinating in that
you've got all this recent evidence that
rhyming flavors are memorable and
believable yet they are use less and
less and less and I think that can only
be explained by the the mixed
motivations of marketers and creatives
now I would argue that their rhymes
aren't used as much as they should
because they have fallen out of fashion
in the marketing Cerrone cool yeah
exactly
but they're uncool to your fellow
professional and who cares what your
fellow professional thinks in terms of
sales yeah exactly so you they shouldn't
care every right they do because if you
yeah exactly if you want to signal your
professional expertise
it won't does not do that you know use
of cutting-edge techniques does that or
something that is probably very abstruse
does that but that's not our as marked
as our core role so I think one big game
bets the original point one big pitfall
of is to advertise to our peers rather
than advertise to our our customers and
that I think happens far more compete
them people admit yeah I got a sense of
this during our last conversation and I
also got this when speaking to Rory's a
big proponent of the fact that people in
advertising agencies a lot of the time
would sooner come up with an advert
which failed but was not risk taking and
liked by their superiors than one which
sometimes actually was more successful
with the market but adds risk on to
their back because if you decides to
fall
the new yes with with your adventurous
advert and it doesn't go well you never
have that but it's it's just like look
at the lineage of things that we've got
behind us it was it was all gonna work
how did it not work we followed the
formula lutely
so it's this wonderful thing of like
risk if you say is being distinctive and
risky for a brand no it's not because it
gives you the greatest probability of
success easy it risky for the individual
involved absolutely you know your plan
spot-on about this lineage you know if
you are a beer brand and you decide to
sponsor a table to this team and it goes
horribly wrong a lot all ads and all
sponsorships can then you will end up
getting fired because you haven't got
that body of work to show it's a
sensible decision if you decide to
sponsor a football team like every other
football brighter beer brand does when
it goes wrong you can say ah it wasn't a
stupid idea bud - it Carling do it seven
so do it so I think I think you're
absolutely right there is a there's a
misalignment of motivations between the
what's often called the agent the
employer or the marketer and the
principal that is the brand or that all
the shareholders and that principal
agent problem explains an awful lot of
bizarre decision-making the part of
brands why so few a distinctive why so
few admit floors and platforms take why
so few adopt rhymes yet this mismatch of
motivations I think explains an awful
lot I love it well I think there's some
really good a real good framework there
for people to begin to look at how
they're how they're planning their
advertising campaigns we are going to do
a new section which I'm very excited for
which is called
what phrases do lecture most in
marketing I'm gonna go I'm gonna go
first let number one phrase that I hate
in marketing is pivot pivot yeah you
know we're just we're just good yeah
we're gonna pivot the brand direction
when we've really thought recently we
sat down we had a bow-wow when we
realized that we're actually gonna pivot
a little bit on therefore man wow it
really really really gets me
so I think that is smack of all a lot of
multi-language that ease over complex I
mean as far as my pivot just means we
gonna change direction there's a
wonderful study done by a guy called
Daniel Oppenheimer
Princeton and it's got the best ever
title for his research paper it's
something like the utilization of
erudite vernacular irrespective of
necessity using long words needlessly
yeah he does because that's the for both
and what he does is he gets abstracts of
other academic papers and these are
often thick with jargon like marketing
writing he shows those abstracts to
people and then he says how intelligent
do you think new author of this abstract
is and then in his other version he
shows another group of people in the
test version the same abstracts that he
has changed the complex language for
simpler language and when those people
rate the intelligence that the author
they think the author is more
intelligent so you've got this bizarre
situation in which marketers and
academics are using this overblown
language in the hope of appearing
intelligent but actually what the
listener takes out is a lack of
intelligence so it's far far better to
speak plainly and simply what's that
Einstein quote it is the mark of a
genius to explain a complex thing in a
simple way is the mark of a charlatan to
explain a simple thing in a complex way
oh go and say that again it is the mark
of a genius to explain a complex thing
in a simple way it is the mark a
charlatan yeah to explain a whip
recorder you don't need to write it down
and the only about that quote is the
attribution there's no way that Einstein
right what phrase do you hate most
there's a lovely face called
Churchillian drift so
this idea that someone who isn't very
famous sitting amazing and then it
gradually just gets attributed to more
immense tine wine so if people are
interested in the genuine tribution
there's an amazing website called quote
investigator you put the quote in and it
has this lovely like half a page on who
first said it where it came from
spreading it so ancestry.com but for a
quote right to uh I think it's we are
what we repeatedly do excellent
therefore is not an act but a habit and
everyone attributes that to Aristotle
Aristotle but it's just not him at all
and that's a huge medium pulse which is
on the same thing I don't know would you
call it what's that word when you see
where where words have come from what's
the body
oh yeah it's a tamale it's like that but
it's the the movement of a quote okay so
what let's give us give us a phrase that
you hey okay so the one at the moment
I'm most hey and it's quite a few
remarks about hey ease a trust crisis so
this more and more again article after
article it's a very respected titles and
and bodies where they're talking about
the crisis and trust that people trust
brands less than they ever have ever
done the problem of this is although it
gets repeated again and again in
articles and presentations there is no
evidence for it it is amazing it's how I
a piece of fake information can just
spread so spend a little bit of time
looking this there are three long-term
trackers of how much people trust
organizations
so there's Adelman data now if you just
read the Adelman reports into trust you
could often come away with the
impression that we are in the trust
crisis if you print out the data tables
from every one of their thirty reports
and you print them out and you plot them
you see is the trust in brands or
businesses you know bounces around from
year to year but it's essentially flat
or slightly rising the other one is I
think it's um eeep sauce mori
they've got a thing called the it's the
variety the veracity index and it looks
a trust in professions and they've
studied twenty or thirty professions
over the Backson early 1980s and again
they are trusts in professions is either
flat or rising I think the only
profession that is in massive decline is
the church and that has very specific
reasons and then the third body of
evidence that people use of this trust
crisis is the AAA so the advertising
Association and what they've done is is
this weird sleight of hand in that the
evidence that they have is that
favorability it towards advertising is
dropping and they show that over about
20 years so you see see this kind of
long drop in favorability towards
advertising and then like last eight or
ten years it's flattened out when they
show trust which they've only measured
for about ten years they say well trust
eight which is pretty flat maybe with a
very small decline that correlates with
favorability and because favorability is
down over twenty years well there must
be a trust crisis so you've always got a
de ones data which shows Trust is
increasing but often the reporting
around it suggests that there's a crisis
because what often happens is because
those numbers are bouncing around if you
would just select certain time periods
by picking which data set you compare
you can create a drop so you've got that
data being misused then you've got the
hips awesome or a date which is
brilliant but when journalists report it
they'll often pick the one profession
that that year happens to have dropped
and then you've got this AAA data which
really shows a very different story
about favorability towards ad
so there's no evidence that Trust is
dropping and that creates a problem
because it ends up with the wrong
solutions if you think Trust is in
crisis as in it's lower than it's ever
been
you need a new solution to solve it if
you think trust in brands and
advertisers is low but it's always been
low which is what the evidence suggests
well then you can turn to tried and
trusted techniques that brands have used
in the past and again there are lots of
ideas from psychology about how you can
build trust in a brand now make big
public pronouncements don't do digital
targets advertising the more public a
statement the more believable it is and
I've done some research on that make
people feel that you've put a huge
amount of money behind your campaign
there's an idea called costly signaling
that the believability of a message
Rises with its perceived expense so
extravagant advertising unnecessary
whitespace long SEC links great creative
feats all boost the believability of an
ad even you know the media context a bit
running in The Times has a very
different feel from running in the start
so hate that phrase because it's not
true yet it mindlessly gets passed from
one person to another and it has a
danger it leads us this phrase leaders
to the wrong solution the solutions the
try and trust solutions are out there
but we're ignoring them because we think
we're in this kind of a unique period of
a lack of trust
that's so good some of the ones which I
hate some other word search I hate a
hate content I hate the term content I'm
so sick of content I can't wait for it
to be something else are we creating
content or we drive in content I mean
this is how bad it was that even when I
was on love Island and I walked through
the doors of season one of love Island
and the producers were in the villa
talking about right guys I know that you
all just want to chill out and have a
chat about the day but we just haven't
we haven't driven quite enough content
for the day so we just I'm thinking they
I'm not recording [ __ ] Instagram
stories here like this is supposed to be
my life like if I want to go and talk
about my day that is the content the
fact that as far as you're concerned and
maybe everybody else as well actually is
concerned this [ __ ] boring content is
not my problem
that is so content not a fan of scale
and [ __ ] sick of scale I'm sick of
higher order and I'm sick of meta oh yes
yeah so content pivot scale higher order
and matter they can all get in the sea
yes really there was it that was that
wonderful show room Oh 101 where people
should shove their hated things all
going room 101 yeah and one thing that
you touched on just there which is
talking about some of the power that
advertising and marketing has and I've
been thinking about this about how
central marketing is to the public's
good right so I think marketing can
sometimes be seen as a bit of a dirty
word capitalist capitalizing businesses
trying to make a profit blah blah but
during the current a virus outbreak that
we've got at the moment industries
deemed non-essential have been shutting
down and so people have been noticing a
refocusing of public attention to
important areas of life like health and
family and connectedness and stuff the
way that I see it marketers are able to
affect behavior change in a way that
brute force operational optimizing and
well-meaning emotions can't on their own
so perfect example the NHS has it I
think this stats nearly a half a million
people have signed up to this volunteer
to yeah yes yeah which is amazing right
great campaign but how much more could
that effect have been amplified if every
ounce of behavioral science and
understanding beautiful advertising and
great copywriting and all the rest of it
was harnessed and that's I think this
the fact that you're able to catalyze
what is effective with a non-essential
business you know no one's looking at
advertisers and marketers of behavioral
science guys and say oh for [ __ ] sake
we better keep the lights on they're a
set like they've done that
then stop going to work and I think that
this really ties back to what Rory said
about alchemy to describe marketing's
ability to literally create value and
create change out of nothing yes I think
there's a couple of points there there's
the idea that if you want to reduce life
threatening behavior tactics from
behavioral science or psychology and
advertising can be used one the I'm
interested in at the moment is this idea
of negative social proof so it goes back
to an idea of Robert chilled eaning
where he says if you make a
transgressive behavior seem commonplace
or an anti-social behavior seem
commonplace you remove a sense of
transgression and it becomes more common
still now like all psychology experience
he doesn't just argue this like a
philosopher he just takes a piece of
logic and creates this smooth argument
what he does is go out and run tests to
prove it so the test is goes to the
Arizona Petrified Wood National Park
rigs up CCTV camera by a path and
sprinkles bits of petrified wood on
longer path now the reason he's done
that is there is a problem in that park
with lots of tourists stealing bits of
petrified wood so he want to know how
you can reduce that and where you might
by accident increase that theft rate so
three scenarios first scenario no sign
says getting a kind of a base level of
theft and it's about 3% second scenario
he puts up a sign saying don't steal
it's wrong and theft rates drop by half
about one half percent and then in the
third scenario which I'll come back to
this is what I'm wearing is happening
now he puts up a sign saying 14 tons of
would have been stolen every year and
it's ruining the look at this park now
he then said he says the theft rates go
from remember 3% was the baseline they
jumped to 7.9 percent
so he's worth because if you tell it
people that everyone else is doing this
what people think is well it can't be
that bad I
a bit of a mug not to be doing it you
know you remove this sense of
transgression it becomes more common
still if you then look at government
advertising and sometimes charity
advertising or
a lot of social advertising you see how
regularly this happens so children he
says that the big mistake of government
when there are behaviors they don't want
they often inadvertently use negative
social proof they say you know loads of
you students get drunk
loads of people are carrying knives lots
of people don't attend up for their
doctor's appointment
all of chil Dinis work suggests that
will exacerbate the situation not solve
it so the danger is if you fixate on
people not social distancing or fixate
on people who are stockpiling the
message that people take out is not oh
they're very bad I'm definitely not
going to do it they take out well if
everyone else is ignoring the rules they
can't be that important and we we are a
species that copy people so I absolutely
believe the application of Beira science
can solve or help solve some very
important problems absolutely and the
misapplication of it as well can
pretentiously make it worse yeah yeah
absolutely yeah that's completely true
yeah there was that brilliant study that
you put up about was it was it Peru was
it the Peruvian tax where they created a
lottery on the bottom of the receipt Oh
Taiwan I think I'm renting a Taiwanese
tax so they wanted people to submit
receipts and didn't they want to make
sure they kept a hold of them so they
created a lottery and the numbers were
printed on the bottom of receipt so
everyone obviously kept them and they
forced the supermarket's to give them to
them and and yeah this awesome and you
think population into into you know
policemen they were essentially enforce
their own receipts yeah for something
that it was would have previously been
costly and all the other different ways
that you could have gone about that and
it is by far the the cheapest you know
it requires it requires a printer I mean
they were giving away they were giving
away money for the lottery so it
requires the money the lottery but you
know in real terms nothing compared that
with having to pay an entire division of
people to enforce the [ __ ] the
receipt collection yes whatever it is
yeah I think that's Taiwanese example I
think I'm read about that first on a
Dave Trott blog yes a brilliant example
and there are other examples of
lotteries being used by government so I
think the Swedish have a system where
speed cameras both fine
drivers who are breaking the speed limit
but people who go past the speed camera
below the recommended level they are
entered into a draw away oh good
do you know um Kunz Mets do you know who
that is
yes he's more a Belgian guy into a
social psychology a lovely chap yeah
fantastic guys I had him on had him on
last year did you know about the
Estonian police service and what they've
been doing is this where people get is
this what I think I might have read
about in Rory Sutherland post where do
you get pulled over and yeah they give
people the choice between a very
expensive fine I think it's 300 euros or
something if you get caught speeding or
a half an hour wait yes it just showed
that the whole podcast that I did with
him is about the valuing of time the how
we perceive time from a behavioral
economic standpoint and almost 50% of
people elected to pay this fine rather
than wait half an hour and that's it so
it's so interesting because obviously
presumably if you are caught speeding
it's probably because you have somewhere
to be and you can do with yeah there
quickly which means if I said a mate
would you sit by the side of this road
for 300 euros III don't think Beckerman
probably do that you know does no amount
of money that someone's got that's too
much to not sit by the side of the road
to 300 euros but if you are running 20
minutes late to your daughter's dance
recital or to a gym class or to get to a
meeting or something like yeah you're
prepared to do it under there if I
wonder if they take tape it was phones
away because there's a lot of research
into the idea the unoccupied weights
are painful occupied weights are people
don't seem to mind so what I mean by
that is there was a report in The New
York Times about I think it was one of
the might be a Houston Airport and they
were having lots of complaints about how
long people had to wait to get their
bags at the airport baggage carousel so
what was happening was people would go
through possible control or ever that
they'd walk a minute and then they'd
wait seven minutes to get that back so
the first thing they did was spend loads
of money just trying to make the system
more efficient and hiring more baggage
handlers speeding up the machines
whatever they did and they managed to
shave a minute of the time but they saw
very little reduction in complaints the
next thing they did was rather than try
this kind of engineering technique they
tried a psychological technique which
was all around occupying people's time
so now what happened was as people in
left passport control they were sent on
this kind of securitas walk around the
airport for six minutes so you know they
use all those kind of guides that make
sure people convinced they carousel so
yeah they walked for six minutes get to
the carousel then wait a minute bag
turns up and off they go and when they
did that people's complaint level
plummets because what people didn't like
was standing staring at a carousel with
nothing to do what they didn't mind was
a little walk around and some blind
effort to make it feel yeah yeah so I
think about this all the time when I'm
driving I realize I know for an absolute
fact that a time when there's traffic
I will tend to take a route which may
potentially be both longer and longer if
both in terms of time and in terms of
difference but one which will be less
likely to be nose-to-tail even
accounting for all of that
yes I'm cognizant of the level of
discomfort that I have when being in
nose-to-tail traffic there's a little
bit of effort involved especially if you
drive an automatic car yeah you know if
you're with
cruise control automatic cards basically
a go-kart you just sit on the motorway
yellow whereas I've got to use my foot
I've got to think how far is that go
away from me are [ __ ] this is boring sat
in traffic this sucks like you know I
have that but that's the same thing I
just I want to feel like I'm doing a new
something even if I arrive 15 minutes
later well wonder if there's also an
element of the at one of the other
theories about time is that people find
an uncertain wait like I don't know
whether I'm have to wait 0 minutes or 10
minutes they find that much more
irritating than someone saying you will
wait 8 minutes that's certain Rory was
it Rory that did the he talks about a
fever no was it not the one that was it
not the one for Heathrow which so people
waiting to get into Heathrow the
audience will know I use this I must
drop this all the time so if it's miss
miss accredited to Rory like one of
those quotes that's come through the
wrong everything that's cool get
eventually attributed Rory salade Dave
Trott waiting to get into the security
scanners at Heathrow they were
struggling they looked at operational
fixes for it and instead of that they
just put up signs saying 45 minutes from
this point 30 minutes from this point 15
minutes from this point and it the
number of complaints attack let's link
this back to yes kuroh virus so Boris
Johnson his announcement when he said we
are going to be under quarantine we are
going to be under lockdown you are not
to leave the house except for these
things and I'm thinking to myself he's
gonna have to say a time frame he has to
give a time frame because if what else
has an open ended there is no time frame
in this and it was really cleverly
worded the way that he said it he said
that we will review this after three
weeks
so in that case probably the people to
learn from a Disney so firstly they do
well I hadn't heard about Heathrow so I
don't know who that to be tripped about
it but what Disney do is not only to
they give you you know on a like
Disneyland Paris wherever as you go to
the ride it says 45-minute way or our
way so they make the wait certain and
therefore less painful the second thing
that they do very cleverly
is they overestimate the way time so if
they
put up they think it's now what they
really think is it's 50 minutes so when
you get to the end I alway only took 15
minutes I've saved
I've saved 10 minutes on an amount of
time that they made you say yeah which
is no one whereas if it said oh it's
going to be 40 minutes you'd have been
really annoyed so maybe there is a
technique there and it because it's the
end that's particularly important is
that there's a whole body of ideas
called the peak end rule which is the
two moments where disproportionately
likely to remember an experience or the
height of the worst thing on the bass
thing the peak and the end the final
moment so ending the queue on that
positive realization that this was
quicker than you'd expected again is
another very very positive thing so he
can there's a could be a helical noise
it's wonderful applications of it you
need to start seeing restaurants
particular hotels coming up with ways of
making those final moments of the
experience very positive so rockers
normally if you just leave it a spurned
the norm the end of the meal the end of
the stay is normally the the worst part
you know you get the bill and shuffle
out into the cold world there are
restaurants like Flatiron where they
give you this tiny little pair of steak
knives as your you should if you get
your bill and then as you wander out
you're gonna hand those steak knives in
and they give you a little free ice
cream so people end on a higher an
unexpected a benefit
so the yeah there's lots of applications
that pecan rule to anyone who's trying
to custom make customer experience
because most people making customer
experience are fixated on making a good
impression at the beginning important
but what you should also do is that give
us much time energy and effort into
thinking how do you how'd you end on a
high wasn't there
a study done on people having endoscopy
oh yeah that's that's the original
experiment for karna Minh Andrade amar
who came up the idea of the pecans do
you know that yes so can you tell me
because I've been misquoting this for
the last two and a half years and I'd
really like to get it straightened out
well or I've been misquoting it I went
for about a year with the wrong I was
talking about the principal-agent
vibration admit this the principal-agent
problem and had a picture of ste
and Rossi came up with the idea it was
only after about a year and I found out
it was completely the wrong Steven Ross
Rory Sutherland it was I think he was
like so you've just got Steve jazz
singer in New York City or something I
love standing there
blathering on anyway sorry D yeah I
think what happened in that car narrator
my experiment they get six hundred odd
genuine colonoscopy patients so a
15-minute painful medical procedure and
all those patients are given a handheld
monitor and this monitor buzzes every 15
minutes and when it buzzes there's a
dial on the monitor oh so they did a
little handheld thingy
there's a dial that the patients have to
turn saying zero no pain at all to ten
excruciating pain so the psychologists
get 15 experiencing self ratings and by
experiencing today self they mean in
moment ratings fifteen ratings then
after the operation as the patient is
leaving the hospital they stop the
patient and ask them to reflect back on
the operation it's an entirety and say
how bad it was same scale zero to ten
they then go and find those patients a
month later same question rate the
operation so now they've got fifteen
ratings from the experiencing self those
in moment ratings and to remembering
self ratings so you have post-operation
reflections the the expectation before
they did the experiment was the number
should correlate reasonably well but
that's not what they found there's only
a kind of loose correlation what
correlated far better were two moments
in particular in the operation so the
peak experience so for colonoscopy
the moment of most pain and then the
final moment of that colonoscopy so what
they argued was that it's the peak and
the end moment are disproportionately
likely to be remembered and then in
their follow-up study what they do is
they get more patients going for
colonoscopies randomize them into two
groups some get the standard 15 minute
operation which is really painful
because this probe is being moved around
inside them the other group exactly the
same 15 minutes and then the surgeon is
instructed to leave his probe or herb
robe in the patient perfectly still so
it it's there's minor discomfort for
that extra two minutes not the
significant pain now from a logical
point of view they've just added on in
that second version two extra minutes of
mild pain it should be worst it's got 15
minutes of bad pain two minutes of minor
pain but just as the Pecan Ross yes
because the final moment is less painful
people when they reflected back
remembered that operation is less
painful and most importantly they were
about ten percent more likely to turn up
for follow-up appointments so yeah
absolutely the that colonoscopy study in
very controlled circumstances in life or
death circumstances potentially show how
important it is to shape people's final
moment at the experience that is that's
literally life-changing you know for
some people the the power of
understanding our motivations and also
it shows it's why I'm reading a lot of
evolutionary psychology most of it to do
with sort of mating and dating at the
moment but even with that the fact that
we are so at the mercy of the ways that
our brains work our cognitive biases our
predispositions our prejudices against
ourselves and others are existing thorpe
and all of this stuff and um it's I
think it's why I find it just endlessly
interesting the bottomless ly
fascinating stuff to be able to look
under the hood and actually see what's
going on and then then you can go
actually we can do this thing which is
completely counterintuitive to make this
this colonoscopy two minutes longer I
remember I remember reading I think
someone had interpreted that and ad
quote tweeted it with something to the
effect of
the most altruistic and caring thing you
can do for your child if they're going
through a pediatric surgery is to ask
the surgeon to extend the length of the
surgery just a little bit to bring them
back down to do this exact so the final
moments are yes but they have some kind
of choice about going back again it
could be hugely be scared for Hospital
for the rest of their life you know
imagine you've got this traumatic
experience at the dentists or something
like that you know if you can use this
peak and experience module and you can
plug that and you can shape a child's
behavior toward dentist and or doctor
for the remaining in 70 80 90 years of
life yes yes and there's a brilliant
thing can we go back to the bit about
our love of that baby science is it's
not argued from first principles people
on ever though they should never be
saying this definitely works this is
definitely true but they've given you
first of all a bit of robust evidence
through their tests and control but
every situation is different the great
thing is if you're a dentist well you
can recreate that experiment why not
test it for your your your set of
patients in your specific area and see
if it works and you can make you take
make a huge difference absolutely I want
to talk about the Ogilvie gloves
ah yes Singh yes great idea um so
this I think goes back to that idea we
had earlier on which is behavioral signs
in a lot of selfies is great but where
it gets brilliant is when you combine
brilliant behavioral insight with the
wonderful piece of creative thinking
so Oh groovy consult we're over change
were working with a factory where people
were dealing with dangerous equipment
and there's an idea called slightly
controversial idea called risk
homeostasis and I think so controversial
because it was slightly Kazak I think it
has there's evidence that maybe thought
exaggerated the impact but it's still
still there and it the initial studies
were done on I think it was an t J ABS
brakes or anti-lock brakes and when taxi
drivers thinking Germany had these
improved brakes added what they saw was
a much lower decrease in sin accidents
than they expected the argument being
when someone is given a safety mechanism
they could take all the benefit of that
safety mechanism as in lower injury but
actually people sometimes take the
benefit as keeping the injury level the
same and then driving faster so often
safety measures don't have the impact
you would want so that's a problem with
people going to work with sores ever you
know join metal sores every day because
they might become a bit blase about them
and if even if you add in safety
equipment they might then become a bit
more reckless
so what Olga V did was take this idea of
risk homeostasis and with the wonderful
leap of imagination
they gave the workers their gloves black
gloves and then it would have a you know
a skeleton painted on there on the glove
and it was a constant reminder of their
vulnerability and when in the tracking
they showed that people do indeed feel
more vulnerable when they're when
they're wearing these gloves so that
amazed me one of the noisiest
applications of behavioral science
because it's this fusion of great
behavioral science insight but on the
top of it
wonderful leap of creative epic match
imagination it's a perfect example as
well of the alchemy analogy that I
needed to earlier on where it is
creating behavior change / value / pick
geometric of what the end goal is out of
nothing you know imagine them having to
go back to the people that make
industrial band saws and saying right
guys I need you to come up with a
special system that can drop this the
Soraa way immediately release the
mechanism if a Mason's finger gets put
in coming up some special electrodes
that run through the blade to feel if it
touches flesh and if it gets wet or you
just say oh my god like because there
are systems I know that there are
systems failsafe systems in place like
that but you think how much is it
probably Poundland
they probably go if you stock up it
around about Halloween you'll be able to
get loads of those yes of those and
there's a lovely our group from Rory
Sutherland it's it's this differentially
this difference in cost is typical
because his argument is because
businesses normally have this kind of
engineering logical rational mindset
they've been using that for years and
years all the easy cheap wins have been
found already and now it's getting you
know diminishing returns and it's
getting harder and more expensive to
come up with those improvements because
businesses have tended to ignore these
psychological wins there are loads of
them like that glove example that you
can do at very very low cost to have a
remarkable return so I think he's booked
outcome it's wonderfully title because
it it captures this sense of creating
value from no or very little expenditure
yeah it really is
I think as well the the thing that I
keep coming back to I mean talk about
this is the effort which is required by
companies to do the hard thing you know
one of the things have been a common
theme in both our conversations that
we've had and if you haven't already
gone and heard my first episode with
Richard it's it's just as good as this
so go back and listen I'll be linked in
the show notes below
when people have to go do the hard thing
and create this novelty create with
these new ideas it is the hard thing in
the same way as changing your habit as a
normal person is a hard thing so you can
continue to maybe try and eat a little
bit less junk food but beginning a gym
program is real hard right that's
outside of the box thinking we've greedy
at this groove of our standard operating
procedures we spoke about the lineage
the existing adverts that the company's
always gone for the norms that are
within and even take that out further
within an industry we've got norms that
are industry wide as well all these
different ways that people have greased
existing grooves and yet the low-hanging
fruit has been has already been picked
up off the ground you're getting
diminishing returns with rinsing
existing marketing plans or with trying
to further optimize the logistics of
your lean Kaizen production whatever yet
you know that all the different things
and it does it requires somebody to come
in and really reframe everything right
it's look we've tried you eating a
little bit less chocolate there's now no
chocolate left in the house and you go
into the gym at 6 o'clock every morning
that's that's what's happening yeah yeah
I don't know I think it's a the whole
oncoming practice they're lovely analogy
for behavioral science and its strengths
cool I want to see finishes I don't want
to use the c-word too much the new
c-word which is covered oh yeah but I
wanted to talk about some innovative
strategies or some interesting adverts
that you've seen over the last couple of
weeks obviously it's been at a time
where people have been increasingly
releasing stuff so I got a couple of
things that I like that have come out of
you know it's a terrible global pandemic
which is ravaging health and economy in
equal measure but we have to focus on
the positives because it's pointless
focusing on the negatives and some of
the best things for me that have come
out of kovin 19 so far has been whatsapp
group chats have never been as anti
fragile as right now like the quality
except I've got nothing to do with her
than search for game search for memes
and take a look out
each other so that's been fantastic
pornhub giving everybody in Italy and
now I think the UK free access to
premium which is Loki from pornhub them
saying we are a public service which
from a signalling perspective is
unbelievable we are so important that
we're gonna give you during a time of
crisis we know that you need this which
is just like it's so clever
it's beyond beyond clever right Patrick
Stewart reading a sonnet a day have you
seen this Patrick Stewart from Star Trek
reads a sonnet today on his Twitter its
encapsulated in the title um home
workouts I think the number of people
have been giving away I've got
soviet-built up north a propane fitness
Ryan Fischer from across the chaulk in
America all been just throwing out that
top level top top top level programming
for free I mean yeah there's you can get
bored of doing burpees in your living
room but like this is keeping it as
exciting as you can get and I think
that's been really good and I've noticed
a massive great a sense of social unity
as well you know like even just in my
house so to two housemates I don't think
we've ever asked each other how they're
doing as much and it's not it's not got
anything at all to do with I'm not
worried about either of them they're
both like in their young 20s so they're
essentially made of rubber and magic you
could throw the fine um but hey man how
are you how's yeah how's work oh this is
a good did this podcast us not ah how
well you know it's just like everything
investment in everyone's been turned up
by by sort of 20 30 % I think walking
past my neighbours during my one my one
allocated outdoor trip of the day
walking past my neighbours and hey how
are you some old gentleman yes as I
walked past in short he said I saw no
I'd be wearing shorts too if I had legs
like yours thank you strange man
but yeah that's that's some of the
things that I've enjoyed that have come
out of it but wondered if you'd seen any
campaigns or any changes or anything you
have enjoyed that Guinness adverts one
oh yeah the Guinness hats beautiful
absolutely beautiful it's wonderfully
designed very very clever and I will
bring a lot of amusement people whether
it changes behavior is a very different
thing but that's a separate point maybe
I think your point of what's interesting
is there's a lovely GK Cheston phrase
along the idea of the way to love every
anything is to realize it might be lost
and perhaps when you have you know
social contacts or most of social
contacts taken away you realize how
precious is so yeah I think that about
that's I think a key point the one I was
gonna mention and I think is the flip
side of all those positives nor as you
said he's in the Sunday Times there was
talk about one of the supermarket's
raising their their prices and I think
brands have got to be very very careful
about transgressing what I've seen is
fairness norms so there is a study done
by a guy called Werner Guth back in 1982
called the ultimatum game and Guth is at
the University of Cologne comes up with
this wonderfully simple tab to people
never meet each other they don't know
each other one is the proposer one is
the receiver they'd given a small amount
of money
well the propose is given a small amount
money say a tenner and the proposer is
told split that money between you and
the receiver as you think fit and they
get to split the money so it could be
5050 it could be 8020 in their favor and
then the receiver has two options except
the splits as has been given there's no
negotiation hmm except the split or
refused it and both parties get nothing
now before you through these experiments
the standard economic belief was the a
receiver would accept pretty much
anything you know you've been given a
tenner you only offer me one pound you
keep knowing
logically I should just keep the pound
because I'm worse off if I don't but
what happens is if the offer is a blow
about 20% more than half of people will
refuse it they would rather both people
got nothing and the unfair behavior was
punished than the small amount of cash
so it's an argument that people will go
to quite big lengths even across
themselves to punish unfair behavior now
there's other experiments by a
tournament where he shows the people
taking advantage to push up their prices
in times of crises are definitely seen
as unfair so simple thought experiment
he says imagine there's a a hardware
store that sells snow shovels for 15
quid 50 dollars that were biscuit Canada
there's a big snowstorm they push up to
the price to $20 is that fair
and I think 82% of people say that's not
fair not fair so what I would caution to
brands is don't try and make a quick
buck out of people's desperation and
need if you are caught pushing up your
prices even if it's just a farmer's way
of managing demand or supposedly
justifiable from standard economics
don't do that because it will be seen as
unfair and people will go to quite big
lengths to punish me I've noticed a
severe uplift in brands leveraging
social goodwill over the you know the
amount of this is the pay pay walls are
being removed I don't know whether the
Spector free coffees oh they talked
about it didn't they yeah the free
coffees to the NH oh I don't know I saw
each other's tweet about they should do
it and Fraser Nelson's response maybe
that was maybe that was all that I saw
at the NHS I think's cafe near I'm pret
originally were giving them free copies
when there's my own free mask yeah
wonderful
my best friend Youssef he he is a first
year doctor now working in intensive
care the immediate missions and he said
that
felt really good that after working like
two days on two nights on of 14 hours
each he was told that NHS staff were
going to get 20% off at Pizza Express
which is basically a coupon hour and
keep it for afters yeah the UM I had a
point here about brands weaponizing
goodwill at the moment which which it
definitely feels to me like there is a
little bit of going on at the moment in
the bottles I'm the company go ahead
oh so because hey we do we mention that
word that you hate mmm I know I might
have said a year ago brand purpose and
one of the reasons always hate that
phrase was it it was if wanted the
plaudits for moral ethical behavior
without the hard work of actually doing
more like we're doing moral ethical
babies ok ad which talks about our
virtue at least we're now in a situation
where there is a cost being attached no
giving everyone free coffee or Facebook
giving hundred million dollars of ads
away at least they are putting their
money where their mouth is so yes there
might be it positively we could call it
enlightened self-interest I would much
rather that than the previous situation
of you know Gillette ads where it's just
posturing not action I love it look
Richard illiterate actually keep this
getting on all afternoon so I'm I'm
gonna hassle you to come back on the
choice factory your book will be linked
in the show notes below Astro 10 your
company will also be linked to what else
should people check out other than your
amazing Twitter actually what you on
Twitter at our chaton so chaton is sh o
t t RN and well the only other thing is
keep an eye out so I've started doing
some of the research for the hasn't got
a name yet but no choice factually too
so hopefully early next year I have a
second book out well I mean you've got
nothing else to do at the moment right
I know businesses yeah well is this game
better now yeah yes last week it was a
very very bleak but yeah you said before
we start it in nine months time a lot of
babies and a lot of books happening
European yeah if you go if you get
pregnant in the next nine months it's
gonna be very straight look it's you're
phenomenal to have on I really really
love having you here and I can't wait to
get you back choice Factory Richard's
Instagram is Twitter and the link to ask
returned his company will be in the show
notes below if you've got any questions
comments or feedback you know where to
go get at me actress will X wherever you
follow me like share and subscribe if
you new here
thank you for tuning in but for now
Richard thank you so much one fantastic
thanks a lot
[Music]